हेलो गैस आप सबका स्वागत है नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी के सेकंड लेक्चर में मेरा नाम
है आयुष पाठक और हमने ऑलरेडी एक लेक्चर कर
लिया था नेट सिक्योरिटी पे इस पे हमने
काफी बेसिक चीजें नेटवर्किंग की जानी थी
नेटवर्क्स क्या होते हैं बेसिक हब्र्स
डॉक्टर फीचर्स क्या होते हैं आईपी एड्रेस
नायक एड्रेस बेसिक लेवल पे क्या होता है
वो चीज ध्यान में समझी थी लास्ट लेक्चर
में ठीक है तो आज हम को आगे बढ़ाने वाले
हैं हम ट्रिंग में से आगे बढ़ते रहेंगे जो
हमने आधे पे रॉकी थी इसलिए हम आगे बढ़ेंगे
और साथ में हम आपको और भी चीज करके दिखाई
रहेंगे जहां-जहां जरूर पड़ेगी मतलब लेफ्ट
के अलावा जहां भी आपको प्रेजेंटेशन की
जरूर होगी या प्रैक्टिकल जरूर होगी सब कुछ
आएगा ठीक है अब देखिए स्टार्टिंग में
थोड़ी थ्योरी तो आपकी रहेगी वो तो है ही
लेकिन बाद में आपको प्रैक्टिकल भी नजर
आएगा और ज्यादा ठीक है ना तो लास्ट लेक्चर
के लिए बोल रहे हैं तो ठीक है वो मत करिए
आप लोग
लेफ्ट कंप्लीट कीजिए उसका स्क्रीनशॉट दाल
दीजिए
उतना हो सकता है ना उसमें तो प्रमोशन है
हमारा अगर आपको लिखने में पोस्ट करके हमें
टैग नहीं करना है तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
इससे दिखता है की हां कितने लोग इसको फॉलो
कर रहे हैं और उससे कई फायदा मुझे भी होता
है ना अगर आप वो कर रहे हैं अगर आप फीडबैक
देते हैं तो मैं समझ सकता हूं की आपने वो
चीज किया है तो उसमें कुछ हुआ है ये
दिक्कत ए रही है समझ में नहीं ए रहा है तो
मुझे और ध्यान दूंगा ठीक है ना चलिए तो आज
से आज जो भी टेस्ट मिलेगा जो भी आजकल मेरे
को मिलेगा जो भी लाइव चल जाएगा आज उसको आप
लोग अपने स्ट्राइक कीजिएगा साथ में लेक्चर
के साथ ठीक है चलिए
सबसे पहले आए थे हम लोग यही पे अपनी मोडल
वापस से इसको याद ना हो मॉडल्स यहां पर आप
आएंगे
यहां पर हमने पहले नेटवर्क फंडामेंटल से
स्टार्ट किया था मैं इस पे राहत हूं तो
नेटवर्क फंडामेंटल्स में पुरी कर ली थी
सेकंड लैब हमने जो शुरू हुई थी तो मैं
इसको ओपन कर लेट हूं अब देखिए
मैंने आपको यहां पर तोपॉलजिस्ट के बड़े
में बताया था स्टार्टिंग में और हमने ये
इसकी क्वेश्चंस को सबमिट कर दिया था तो एक
क्वेश्चन ये र गया था लास्ट टाइम मैंने
कहा था की आप देख लीजिएगा तो एवं देख लिया
इसमें तो इसको भी खत्म ही कर लेते हैं अभी
तो बेसिक तू प्रोसेस के बड़े में मैंने
आपको बताया था कौन-कौन सी बताया था मैं
आपको बताता हूं स्टार्ट तू क्लोज जी इस
तरीके की दिखती है ठीक है बस इस तरीके की
दिखती है रिंग टोपोलॉजी कुछ इस तरीके की
है ठीक है ना तीन तू प्लस के बड़े में
हमने बात की थी
ये आपको टोपोलॉजी की फिलोस के बड़े में
बताया ठीक है कैसे कम करती है वो समझ गए
की इसमें क्या गड़बड़ी है इसमें ठीक है ना
नेक्स्ट कर लेते हैं इसको देखिए ये रिंग
तो प्रपोज हुई है
रिंग टोपोलॉजी ने कुछ इस तरीके से डाटा का
ट्रांसफर होता है इसमें बताया था की इसमें
जो प्रॉब्लम होती है वह यह होता है की अगर
कहानी बीच में तो फ्रेंड्स देखिए आप देखते
हैं जैसे ये जो रेड लाइट है ये बेटा पैकेट
से एक्चुअली में ठीक है आपको पता ही होगा
डाटा पैकेट के फॉर्म में आता है उसको भी
हम देखेंगे आगे पैकेट के बड़े में तो
फिलहाल ये समझिए डाटा सेंड हो रही है कुछ
इस तरीके से हैंड हो रही है ठीक है मतलब
इधर वाले को लेफ्ट वाले को लेफ्ट वाले पे
डाटा भेजनी है तो वो ऊपर वाले के थ्रू
होते हो जाएगी या फिर नीचे वाली होते हो
जाएगी ठीक है ना तो इसके फ्लावर्स क्या थे
इसके फ्लावर्स कुछ इस तरह किया था देखिए
मुझे फर्स्ट चाहिए था की अगर बीच का केवल
डॉ होता है तो पूरा नेटवर्क की ऐसी तैसी
हो शक्ति है ठीक है दिखता हूं मैं आपको
ऐसे देखिए अब यही पर अट गए तो इसमें करना
कैसा आगे आपको अपने माउस कर्सर को किसी एक
पीस बनाना चाहिए अपने आप कैची का समझ
जाएगा ठीक है इसी तरह बन जाएगी यहां पर
आपको कहानी से भी स्टार को कट कर देना है
तो कुछ यहां से कट करना क्लिक कर दीजिए ये
देखिए यहां पर ये तार जो है वो कट चुका है
अब डाटा ट्रांसफर जो है तो रिंग तो
अपॉलिजी का कम तमाम हो चुका है ठीक है ये
इसका मेजर फ्लो है
नेक्स्ट कर लेते हैं इसको
इस तरीके से यह जो बैकबोन है इसके थ्रू
सारे कनेक्टर है आपस में आपको बताया था
मैंने सो नेक्स्ट कर लेते हैं अब देखिए
डाटा इसे सेंड इन बोथ लेफ्ट और राइट
डायरेक्शन डाटा जो यहां से जा रहा है वो
धुन 10000 है और ये जो बीच वाली केवल है
ये एक तरीके से बैक बोन का कम कर रही है
इसके थ्रू ही साड़ी टाइम के पास जा रहा है
ठीक है चलिए अब इसमें मेजर फ्लो ये है की
ये बड़े अमाउंट ऑफ डाटा नहीं कर सकता
क्योंकि इसी केवल साइज डाटा जा रही है तो
अगर हम बहुत ज्यादा डाटा इसमें भेज देते
हैं एक साथ तो वो यहां पर क्या हो जाएगा
दिक्कत कर देगा ठीक है अब इस प्रैक्टिकल
देखते हैं प्रैक्टिकल यही है की हमें
जल्दी यहां पे डाटा को सेंड करना है तो
देखिए यहां पर ये लिखा है कंप्यूटर कौन से
कंप्यूटर वन पे सेंड हो रहा है उसका कुछ
चेंज करना है आप चेंज कर दीजिए कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है कहानी से कहानी सेंड कीजिए अब
सेंड कर रहे हैं तो एक पैकेट निकाल के ए
रहा है देखिए ठीक है अब आपको क्या करना है
आपको ये सेंड पैकेट बटन को इतने जोर से
बार-बार लगातार ठीक करना है जोर से मतलब
लगता है इतने सीक्वेंटली करना है की आप
यहां देख सकते हैं नेटवर्क में जो ब्लू
ग्रीन रेड जा रहा है सब डाटा पैकेट है ठीक
है ये बहुत ज्यादा स्लो करने लगे हैं आपको
दिखेगा अभी यहां पर अभी एक्सेस ही हो
जाएंगे तब जो है नेटवर्क कम करना बैंड कर
देगा
कई बार लगातार ठीक हूं
ये देखिए कितना र गया की आपका डाटा जो है
अट गया ठीक है
सेंड हो गया होगा
उसे करते हैं ठीक है अब इसमें क्या होता
है सेंट्रल डिवाइस को होता है विच अब ये
आउटर कोई भी हो ठीक है
अब हमें नेक्स्ट करता हूं आपको दिखता हूं
कैसे हो रहा है देखिए मां लीजिए इस वाले
को इस वाले से बात करनी है तो ये मेडियन
मीडियम में जो है मी में जो है आपका राउटर
है जो भी हो उसके लिए टच हो रहा है ठीक है
ना और यहां पे मैं हफ्ते के सैंपल दे रहा
हूं की अगर हां वो तो फिर भेजो है लेकिन
यहां पर आप समझ लीजिए स्विच ऑफ है ठीक है
ना नेक्स्ट करता हूं उसमें अब आपको खुद से
भी इसमें सोचती रहती है और मेरे ख्याल से
आपको समझ में ए भी रहा होगा की इसमें क्या
इशू हो सकता है
वो यही हो सकता है की अगर 20 वाला डिवाइस
है ठीक है तो पूरा नेटवर्क बैंड हो जाएगा
मतलब अगर आपके राउटर को आप किस चीज को कोई
प्रॉब्लम हो जाति है
प्रॉब्लम हो जाति है आपका नेटवर्क जो है
बैंड हो जाएगा तो वही चीज यहां पे आपको
अपने कर्सर को अपने राउटर यहां पे ले आना
है देखिए यहां थोड़ा बन जाएगा अब वैसे
क्लिक करना है ये टूट जाएगा ठीक है अभी
टूट गया
तो इतना डायग्राम और बढ़िया तरीके से मतलब
एनीमेशन से ट्रैक मैं आपको समझा रहा है तो
मेरे ख्याल से आपको इसमें विदाउट अब नहीं
होगा और फिर भी है तो आप पूछ सकते हैं
जरूर कमेंट में पूछ सकते हैं बेटा पूछ
सकते हैं ठीक है
और एक बार बता डन की ज्यादातर अगर आप अपने
डाउट्स को प्रीवियस करते हैं इन वीडियो को
भी वीडियो प्रीमियम हो रही होती है उसे
टाइम पूछेगा तो ज्यादा फॉक्स देगा ज्यादा
ध्यान दिया जाएगा ठीक है ना ऐसा इसलिए
नहीं की बात ध्यान दीजिएगा पर हां उसे
टाइम मछली बैठे होते हैं देखने के लिए
डाउट ठीक है तो उसे टाइम आप करेंगे तो वो
आपका थोड़ा ज्यादा है और हम भी हमें
मोटिवेशन मिलेगा तो चलिए आप लोग फॉलो कर
रहे हैं साथ में चलिए तो नेक्स्ट कर देता
हूं उसको और हां लास्ट वीडियो में एक
फीडबैक मिला था मुझे की थोड़ा स्पीड धीरे
करिए तो मुझे याद ए गया अभी तो उसको धीरे
करते होगा|
देखिए मैंने आपको आईपीएल के बड़े में
बताया था मैंने आपको क्लासेस के बड़े में
बताया था की क्लासेस में रुकते हैं और
मैंने यह भी कहा था की क्लासलैस वाला भी
एक कॉन्सेप्ट होता है ठीक है मतलब यहां पे
क्या है की इस क्लास ये है इसमें यहां से
लेक यहां तक एड्रेस होंगे क्लास बी है
यहां से लेक यहां से एड्रेस होंगे इस
तरीके से एड कर दिया गया है ठीक है अभी
स्टैंडर्ड है तो यह क्रिएट डिवाइस किसने
किया है तो अब इसमें क्या देखिए कुछ अपने
रिजल्ट भी आपकी पब्लिक के लिए सब चीज का
कम है लेकिन क्लासलैस की हम बात करते हैं
ठीक है सब निटिंग में हम क्लास करते हैं
अब क्लासेस मतलब क्या है क्लासेस मतलब मैं
आपको भी समझता हूं पहले इसको ओपन कर लेते
हैं देखिए जैसे आपने एक एग्जांपल है की
यहां पर इनका एक नेटवर्क है मतलब ये
इंटरनेट है आपका ये आपका आउट होता है ये
आपका स्विच है और ये अलग-अलग डिपार्मेंट
से कनेक्ट है मां लीजिए आपका एक
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन एक अकाउंटिंग डिपार्मेंट है
एक ह्यूमन रिसोर्स डिपार्मेंट है और एक
फाइनल डिपार्मेंट है ठीक है तो डिपार्मेंट
कर दिया है खाने का मतलब क्या अकाउंटिंग
का एक नेटवर्क होगा ह्यूमन रिसोर्सेस
नेटवर्क भी सब नेटवर्क्स में डिवाइड है
ठीक है सब नेटवर्क्स मिल जाएगा जैसे यहां
पर हमने सब क्लासेस किया था क्लास वाले
चीज में हमने क्लासेस डिवाइड किया था उसे
तरीके से यहां पे सब नेटवर्क कर देते हैं
ठीक है अब इसका मतलब क्या है
तो वहां पे कोई भी ए बी सी डी ए क्लास
नहीं र जाति है ठीक है कोई भी ए बी सी दी
वाला कॉन्सेप्ट खत्म हो जाता है
जा सकता है फिर भी बता देता हूं अगर आप एक
जैसे तू है तो ये 8 बीट का है ठीक है
एडमिट कार्ड
192 है आपका ठीक है तो कुछ 8 बिट्स में
होगा
ठीक है अगर यही 8 बीट जीरो जीरो जीरो जीरो
जीरो जीरो जीरो जीरो होती है ठीक है तो ये
बनेगा जीरो और ये अगर वन वन वन वन वन वन
वन वन वन होती है तो ये बनेगा 255 ठीक है
इसीलिए आपका जीरो से 250 तक पॉसिबल राहत
है कांबिनेशन
बताया की 32 बीट का आपका क्या होता है
डिवाइड करने के बाद तीन तरीके का एड्रेस
बंता है
एक आपका होता है नेटवर्क एड्रेस ठीक जो
आपके नेटवर्क पॉइंट करवाता है नेटवर्क
को मिल शक्ति है वो होता है ठीक है जी तरह
आपका होता है डिफॉल्ट गेटवे एड्रेस
बोल सकते हैं वो होता है आपका डिफॉल्ट
गेटवे का एड्रेस ठीक है जिसमें
चलिए जैसे मां लीजिए की आपका एक कोई आईपी
एड्रेस है ठीक है आ मां लीजिए आपका एक
एड्रेस है कुछ इस तरीके का ठीक है
अगर आपका ये होम आउटर आउटर का आईपीएस है
सब का तो मुश्किल यहां पे आपका स्लैश 24
और होता है स्लैश 24 का मतलब क्या है मैं
कुछ लेट हूं कोई भी आईपी एड्रेस जो है
इसमें मां लीजिए ये आपका आईपी एड्रेस है
तो इसमें 1 मिनट यहां होंगे बताइए
सॉफ्टवेयर
क्यों होंगे आईटी इसकी होगी और आते इसकी
होगी ठीक है तो इसमें क्या होता है इसमें
कुछ नेटवर्क पार्ट होता है
नेटवर्क पार्ट
और कुछ आपका होस्ट पार्ट होता है ठीक है
नेटवर्क पार्ट है नेटवर्क भी डिफाइन करता
है नेटवर्क इतने बिट्स नेटवर्क एड्रेस
रिप्रेजेंट कितने बीट से होगा और होस्ट
पार्ट डिफाइन करता है की पोस्ट यानी जो भी
एपिडर्मिस को मिलने वाले हैं वो कितने बीट
से मिल के बनेंगे ठीक है अब ये समझ सकते
हैं तो जल्दी क्या होता है ये तीन जो होते
हैं ठीक है ये तीन जो तीन जॉकेट्स होते
हैं यानी 88 टोटल होते हैं वो होता है
नेटवर्क बिट्स ये है क्लास थ्री से
रिलेटेड कर सकते हैं प्लासी में भी 24 इधर
होता है नेटवर्क बिट्स के लिए ठीक है
तो ये एक बीट में कितने पॉसिबल
यहां तक ठीक है और इसका
मतलब क्या है इसका मतलब जीरो ही है पूरा
इसका मतलब है आपका 255 ठीक है
तो लास्ट में जो 137 है ये आपका कहां से
कहां तक जा सकता है जीरो से
255 तक ठीक है कहां जा सकता है जीरो से
255 तक क्योंकि ये क्या हुआ आपका नेटवर्क
कितना बना आपका ये पूरा बना नेटवर्क पार्ट
स्टार्टिंग का 3 अपडेट ठीक है सॉरी
स्टार्टिंग का 3 मिनट में नेटवर्क पॉइंट
ये डिफाइन करेगा आपका नेटवर्क को और लास्ट
पार्ट है वो चीज होता रहेगा अलग-अलग
डिवीजन के लिए अलग-अलग बंटी रहेगी ठीक है
पॉसिबल है जिसमें से जो पहले होती है ठीक
है यानी आपका एड्रेस
आपका ये वाला एड्रेस
करता है ठीक है
पहले वाला मतलब है
ये आपका है नेटवर्क एड्रेस
ब्रॉडकास्ट एड्रेस
काउंट नहीं करते हैं ठीक है उसके अलावा आप
बोल सकते हैं की 200 54 आपके बने हैं ठीक
है जो आप उसे कर सकते हैं होस्ट के लिए ये
जनरली हमारे होम एड्रेस में होता है फोन
में एड्रेस में क्लास सी का ही जो होता है
हमारा राउटर होता है कर सकते हैं एक तरीके
से काशी मतलब की इसमें जो 24 बीट होती है
वो नेटवर्क पार्ट होता है जो होस्ट पार्ट
होता है वो 8 बीट का होता है तो हम अराउंड
254 * 54 जो है होस्ट को कनेक्ट कर सकते
हैं ठीक है
अब देखिए नेटवर्क सिर्फ 24 नहीं होता है
और भी होता है जैसे मैंने बताया 16 भी
होता है 16 मतलब की यहां पर आपका जो ये
नेटवर्क पार्ट है ठीक है
दो अपडेट है वो आपके नेटवर्क को 25 करेंगे
ठीक है और आगे के जो यहां वाले हैं ठीक है
ये आपके होस्ट पॉइंट करेंगे ठीक
मीटिंग में क्या होता है इस मीटिंग में
यही होता है की मतलब हम कितने भी हो होस्ट
बिट्स को उठा के कितने भी नेटवर्क पार्ट
में दाल सकते हैं और कितने भी नेटवर्क
फास्ट बॉलर कर सकते हैं खाने का मतलब ये
की होस्ट फोन नेटवर्क को होस्ट में बिट्स
का जो है गौरव होता है ठीक है अब ये बर हो
कैसे हो रहा है कुछ तरीके से हो रहा है
जैसे मां लीजिए की मैंने अभी बताया की आठ
बेटे से मां लीजिए बर हो की चला गया आपके
इसके लिए नेटवर्क के लिए ठीक है सॉरी
नेटवर्क पर आप क्या ए गया पोस्टपेड ने तो
यहां पे क्या हुआ देखिए यहां पे ये हुआ की
आपके जो दो स्टार्टिंग वाले थे ये बन गया
नेटवर्क पार्ट और पीछे वाला दो बन गए आपके
पोस्ट पर ठीक है ना अब इससे क्या होगा
इससे ये होगा की
अगर मेरा नेटवर्क करना होगा तो मैं कुछ ये
पहले चीज मैं आपको बता डन की जी लेंस 24
मिनट होते थे ना मतलब सॉरी ये जो मां
लीजिए अभी मैं कर देता हूं पहले इसको एक
ही कर देता हूं क्योंकि अच्छी तरह से
मैंने आपको कन्फ्यूजन हो जाएगा
कॉन्सेप्ट क्लियर था ठीक है इस तरीके की
नेटवर्क को हम रिप्रेजेंट कैसे करते हैं
हम नेटवर्क एड्रेस लिखने हैं ठीक है
नेटवर्क ध्यान रखिएगा नेटवर्क क्या है
हमारा यहां पे नेटवर्क यहां पे ये है ठीक
है
रिप्रेजेंटेशन
तो यहां बच्चे 16 और यहां के बच्चे
16 ठीक है सॉरी अब यहां
पे क्या होगा यह जो लास्ट वाला अपडेट जीरो
से 255 से जा सकता है ठीक है यानी अब ये
लास्ट वाले दोनों जो अपडेट है उनकी वैल्यू
चेंज होती रहेगी हमने अलग-अलग नेटवर्क और
अलग-अलग नेटवर्क में घुस देने के लिए ठीक
है तो नेटवर्क हो गया
एड्रेस को रखो और बाकी
ड्रेस
के लिए क्योंकि यहां से
ठीक है
ठीक है और इस नेटवर्क को रिपेयर करने के
लिए आपको आगे क्या लगाना पड़ेगा
रिजल्ट पर नेटवर्क एड्रेस
ठीक है अब हम यहां पे क्या का सकते हैं अब
हम यहां पे ये का सकते हैं एक स्लेस्ट
इसको पहले कैट देता हूं इसको मैं ठीक है
अब देखिए हम बात कर रहे हैं पहले अभिलेख
24 नेटवर्क में अगर एक स्लैश 24 नेटवर्क
में आपको दो एड्रेस देता हूं मैं ये दो
एड्रेस देता हूं ठीक है
मां लीजिए
ये आपका एक एड्रेस है ये वालिया ठीक है
दूसरा आपका है
ठीक है देखिए ये आपका दो आईपी एड्रेस में
पहुंचता हूं और अभी आपको मैंने कुछ नहीं
बताया है हमें आपसे कहता हूं की क्या ये
दोनों से नेटवर्क पे हैं क्या ये दोनों
शेर नेटवर्क पे है तो आप अभी कुछ नहीं बोल
पाएंगे ठीक है ना देख के लिए अपने दोस्तों
की सिनेमेटोप में है या नहीं है ठीक है
दोस्तों आप देख लीजिए की नहीं शेर डाटा पे
नहीं है ठीक है लेकिन पहले आपको पूछना
पड़ेगा की इनका सब नेट मास क्या है इसको
आप का सकते हैं देखिए
ये तो मेरे पास नहीं है इसको आप किस दिन
की मैंने सीआईडी नोटेशन ठीक है इसका
आइडिया नोटेशन बताओ यानी ये कितने बीट का
नेटवर्क है ठीक है ना तो अब इसमें बात
क्या आएगी इसमें बात ये आएगी की अगर ये
क्लास सी या फिर स्लैश 24 कहीं है तो
नेटवर्क है इसका मतलब स्टार्टिंग की इतनी
बिट्स रिजर्व्ड है नेटवर्क के लिए तो ये
कांस्टेंट हनी चाहिए ठीक है इतनी बिट्स
कांस्टेंट हनी चाहिए तो क्या दोनों में
फिर से है नहीं से है इसका मतलब स्लैश 24
मिनट
24 मिनट क ये दोनों आईपीएल एड्रेस अलग-अलग
डॉक्टर ने अगर ठीक है
लेकिन यही अगर यह
नेटवर्क होता तो अब क्या कहते हैं अगर ये
श्रेया 16 नेटवर्क है इसका मतलब की जितने
पार्ट इतना पार्ट्स
है
नेटवर्क में हो सकते हैं ठीक है अब दोनों
हो सकते हैं और ये पार्टनर है इसका मतलब
क्या मैंने 8 बीट यहां से बोरो किया था
ठीक है नेटवर्क पार्ट्स से और यहां होस्ट
पार्ट में 8 बिट्स मैंने बोरो किया था तो
8 बिट्स सबने बनाने के लिए इस्तेमाल कर
रहा हूं मैं ठीक है तो यहां सी वाले 8 बीट
सवाल होंगे यहां पर तो इसका मतलब ये है की
ये दो अलग-अलग सब्जेक्ट है ठीक है सॉरी ये
आपके दो अलग-अलग क्रिएट किया हैं इसमें ये
जो पैनल सब नेट है जो पैनल आईपी एड्रेस है
ये कौन सा सब्जेक्ट का है ये इस सब नेट का
है
ये इसका है इसका नेटवर्क का एड्रेस ये है
ठीक और इसका नेटवर्क एड्रेस है
यह इसका नेटवर्क एड्रेस
ठीक है और दोनों हसन में अलग-अलग घुसत र
सकते हैं ठीक है तो मतलब नेटवर्क क्या
किया दो हिस में डिवाइड कर दिया इस तरीके
से बर कम करता है इसके बड़े में आप और
समझेंगे अच्छे से अभी तो बस आपको
कन्फ्यूजन काफी हो रहा हूं अभी तो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है बेसिकली समझते रहिए अभी आप
कुछ दिक्कत नहीं है आगे हम समझाएंगे उसको
अच्छी तरीके से ठीक है प्रैक्टिकल के कुछ
होते रहेंगे आपको समझेंगे साथ में हां मैं
इस तरह मैं करता साबुन मास कुछ नहीं होता
इसका मतलब बस यही है स्लैश 24 नेटवर्क है
ठीक है तो मेरे पास ऐसे होता है मुझे इस
तरीके से लिखने हैं
जितना पार्ट नेटवर्क था उसको वन वन ले
लिया है
वही चीज लिखी हुई है
आप ऐसे लिखेंगे इसको
ठीक है अब सब देखेंगे
हम लोग इस तरीके से
फिलहाल मैं ऑफिस में बैठता हूं ठीक
है
देखिए मैंने आपको सबने मार्क्स बताया भी
क्या होता है
देखिए कितने बिट्स नेटवर्क को दिए गए हैं
वो वाला चैप्टर पर कितने बीट होते हैं तो
ये भी आईपीएल जैसा ही है तो 32 जीबी होना
चाहिए इसमें भी 25 कर देते हैं ये देखिए
ठीक है व्हाट इस रेंज ऑफ एन क्षेत्र
इसका मतलब क्या है इसका
ओके ठीक है
मैंने आपको बताया ऑलरेडी ये चीज की ये
एड्रेस है तो जीरो जीरो जीरो का मतलब होता
है
नेटवर्क कहां से स्टार्ट हो रहा है ठीक है
एक नेटवर्क
कौन सा आईपी हो सकता है ठीक है व्हाट इसे
डी नाम यूज्ड तू आईडेंटिफाई डी डिवाइस दिस
पॉसिबल पर सेंडिंग डाटा तू अंदर नेटवर्क
ठीक है आ कोई भी डिवाइस
उसका कितना राउटर कहते हैं तो राउटर के
एफबी को कौन करता है गेटवे एड्रेस
चलिए
अब ये सब आपको बताता हूं की आप यहां पे
चेक कर सकते हैं विंडोज में कंप्यूटर में
देख सकते हैं ये आपका एड्रेस होता है ठीक
है ये आपका डिफरेंस है इसका मतलब क्या है
इसका मतलब ये है की 255 मतलब
ठीक है
यानी 1992 29 किसके लिए है नेटवर्क पार्ट
है ठीक है तो 192162 29 कांस्टेंट रहेगा
इसमें कोई चीज नहीं आएगा
उसका एड्रेस
रहेगा उसके बाद लास्ट अपडेट में जीरो से
लेकर कुछ भी हो सकता है ठीक है
ये मेरा आउटर का एड्रेस है ठीक है की डेट
आपको कहां से जाना है किसके पास जाना है
ठीक है ये वो एड्रेस है
आपको
चलिए
कोई एन इसका एक तरीके से आप अल्फा में या
नंबर में इन सब में अपलोड कर सकते हैं
ट्रांसलेशन होता है google.com तो उससे
डोमेन नाम कहते हैं तो कंप्यूटर में उसको
उसे दिन कहते हैं ठीक है वही चीज कुछ और
उसमें खास है नहीं
आगे बढ़ते हैं देखिए मैं आपको यहां पे
जितनी भी चीज प्रेजेंटेशन में भी शिफ्ट कर
रहा हूं सब कर कर जाएगी टेंशन नहीं लेना
है ठीक है ये तो स्किप कर रहे हैं स्किप
नहीं होगा कोई चीज है इसका प्राइस है ठीक
है एक-एक करके ए जाएगी अब जैसे अपना ये
बेसिक समझ जाओगे नेटवर्क कैसे ये बनते हैं
अपने और मेरे साथ टोटल
क्या होती है ठीक है इंटरनेट क्या होता है
नेटवर्क डिवाइस मतलब
पिंक करके देखा था ठीक है
प्रोटोकॉल क्या होता है यहां पर
आया था
प्रोटोकॉल एक सेट ऑफ रूल्स होते हैं मतलब
ये डिफाइन करते हैं
की डाटा कैसे ट्रांसफर होगा डिवाइस में
ठीक है अब ये कम डिवाइस के बीच में होता
है ऑलरेडी डिवाइस के बीच में हो सकता है
जैसे जब आप वेबसाइट पे आते हैं मतलब कोई
भी ब्राउज़र में आते हैं कोई साइड ओपन
करते हैं तो वो एचडीबी कम्युनिकेशन होता
है स कम्युनिकेशन होता है आपको ये एफटीपी
से बेस्ट करते हैं तो एफटीसी कम्युनिकेशन
होता है आप मेरे दोस्त हैं तो वहां पे
आपका एसएमटी वीडियो कल का सवाल होता है तो
सबका अपना एक सेट ऑफ रूल्स है ठीक है इस
हिसाब से डाटा ट्रांसफर होता है अलग-अलग
एप्लीकेशन और डिवाइस में ठीक है ये होता
है
अब देखिए मैंने आपको क्या बताया था आपको
मैंने बताया था की 1 नेटवर्क के अंदर एक
जो डिवाइस है ठीक है एक नेटवर्क के अंदर
जो डिवाइस है वारंटी फाइव हो रहा है कैसे
अपने आईपी एड्रेस से ठीक लेकिन डाटा
ट्रांसफर कैसे हो रहा है एक्चुअली में तो
एक्चुअली आंसर होता है प्राइवेट नेटवर्क
में यानी इंटरनल नेटवर्क में लोकल एरिया
नेटवर्क में वो होता है आपके मैक एड्रेस
के थ्रू ठीक है ये क्या कॉन्सेप्ट है भाई
अब इस चीज को समझिए की आपका जो कोई डिवाइस
है वो नेटवर्क में कनेक्ट होता है ठीक
जैसे मैंने आपको भी समझाया था की एक बार
मैं ब्लॉकिंग वगैरा मैंने ऊपर आया था की
राउटर अगर आपका मैक एड्रेस ब्लॉक कर देता
है तब उनको चेंज कर सकते हैं इसको कर सकते
हैं ठीक है तो ये चीज की एक नेटवर्क के
अंदर लोकल ये नेटवर्क के अंदर आपका जो
डाटा ट्रांसफर होता है वो मैं एक एड्रेस
ऊपर होता है ना की आईपी एड्रेस प्रूफ खाने
का मतलब की आप उसे करते हैं आईपी एड्रेस
का मतलब जैसे आप लिख रहे हैं आईपी एड्रेस
आप लिख रहे हैं कोई भी चीज मतलब आईपी
एड्रेस ठीक है इस टाइप की कोई चीज भेज दो
पर इंटरनल नेटवर्क में वो चीज कैसे हो रही
है
तो आप एड्रेस दिया नहीं इसको मालूम है कुछ
दिखता हूं उसके लिए
है तो हर एक डिवाइस जो नेटवर्क में है वो
इस तरीके का एक टेबल अपने पास रखना है
कैसे टेबल तरीके अपने पास रखना है जो
स्टोर करता है आपके आईपी एड्रेस और उनका
मैं एड्रेस को ठीक है मतलब आपकी कंप्यूटर
को पता है की कोई दूसरा डिवाइस है उसका
मैक एड्रेस क्या है ये आपकी कंप्यूटर को
ऑलरेडी पता है ठीक है
भारत जी कैसे पता है अब देखिए जो होता है
जैसे मां लीजिए मैं पिंग लिखना हूं पिंक
192.1 ठीक है तो वो इस टेबल से फ्रेश
करेगा इसका फिजिकल एड्रेस क्या है उसे
एड्रेस जो है आपकी पिंक पैकेट चला जाएगा
ठीक है इस तरीके से होता है इंटरनल
नेटवर्क में ठीक इसी तरह काफी जरूरी है की
अगर आपका
कम आएगा ठीक है तो आईपी एड्रेस इससे आपका
मैच हो रहा है मैक एड्रेस अभी कैसे हो रहा
है अभी कंप्यूटर को कैसे पता की इस टाइप
के ड्रेस पे ये वाला
होता है एयरप्लेन
ठीक हैl
हर एक गैस जो है उसके बाद इतना एक पॉइंट
टेबल बताया आपको ये चीज है अब ये क कैसे
करता है तो ये दो चीज क करता है आरपी
रिप्लाई और एयरप्लेन ठीक है दो चीज पे तो
इसका डायग्रामेटिकली प्रेजेंटेशन किस
तरीके से दिया हुआ है पर हम इसको अपने
तरीके से समझते हैं
ये एक डायग्राम
लिख लेते हैं
पोस्ट सेंड पोस्ट नहीं भेजो ठीक है
तो हमारे होश में क्या किया हमारा होस्ट
मां लीजिए ये डिवाइस है ठीक है डिवाइस
एक रिक्वेस्ट है
और ये बोलना है साथ में यही बोलना है की
कौन है बताओ तेल मी ठीक है अपना एड्रेस
लिख देता है ठीक है जैसे यहां पर हो रहा
है
पैकेट को आएगा उनमें से जिनका यह आईपी
एड्रेस नहीं होगा वो तो इग्नोर कर देंगे
ठीक है इनका भैया एक एड्रेस नहीं होगा तो
इग्नोर कर देंगे लेकिन जी जो है इसके पास
ये आईपी एड्रेस होगा वो रिस्पांस करेगा वो
क्या करेगा
192.168 डॉट 29 डॉट 13 ठीक है अब देखिए
तेल मी ये अपना साथ में अपना भी नेकेड
बताया ठीक है ना
लिखा हुआ है यहां पर
पूछा था
194 16 कहा था तेल मी आते इट्स मेरा मेथड
है जो भी यहां पे मुझे बताओ ठीक है तो
यहां से क्या रिस्पांस आया जो भी वहां पे
था उसने
रिस्पांस किया
की भाई मैं यहां पर हूं ठीक है अपने
ड्रेस कुछ इस तरीके का है ठीक है जो भी है
ठीक है इसमें अपने रिस्पांस किया तो अब
क्या हुआ
तो वो क्या करेगा अपने इआरपी टेबल में
उसको स्टोर कर लगा ठीक है अब ये कुछ कुछ
इंटरनल पे होता राहत है जैसे जैसे एप्लाइड
डिस्कवर्ड करते हैं की ऑडिशन वीडियो है
आपस में इंटर कम्युनिकेशन होता है तो वो
इस तरीके की एफबी रिक्वेस्ट तो सेंड करके
डिटरमिन कर लेते हैं की सामने वाले का जो
है मेकर्स क्या है और फिर जो आपका फर्डर
डाटा ट्रांसफर हो जाता है इसके बाद आप जब
भी कोई भी आईपी एड्रेस की डाटा भेजेंगे
उसके तो आपके टेबल के थ्रू वो उसके नए
थ्रू आपका जो पैकेट है वो सेंड हो जाएगा
ठीक है ये वाला होता है नेट ड्रेस का
इंटरनल नेटवर्क में
क्लोज कर लेते हैं ठीक है
[संगीत]
मतलब
उसे पैकेट को क्या कहा जाता है जो पैकेट
आपका पूछता है की भाई कौन बैठा हुआ है इस
एड्रेस पर कौन बैठा हुआ है ठीक है
ना ये आपका कम हो गया किसका
कल
के बड़े में इसलिए पढ़ा है
और इन जनरल भी आपको पता होना चाहिए
नेटवर्क जो होता है
स्विच में
क्या होता है स्विच आपका खुद ही एक टेबल
इंस्टॉल करता है ठीक है
उसे टेबल में स्टोर राहत है की कौन सा मैक
एड्रेस कौन से पोर्ट पे है स्विच में
फिजिकल पोस्ट होते हैं ठीक है ना यहां पर
राहत है की कौन से ताल पर कौन सा ड्रेस है
ठीक है
तो उसके कोड नंबर चला जाता है ठीक से आईपी
एड्रेस इस्तेमाल नहीं करते हैं ठीक है ना
स्विच ऑफ आईपी एड्रेस का इस्तेमाल नहीं
करते हैं स्विच नेटवर्क में आईपी एड्रेस
को इस्तेमाल नहीं होता है सबका आपके बोर्ड
से मैक एड्रेस होता है लेकिन राउटर में
जरा बात करते हैं जब आप नेटवर्क बात कर
रहे हैं चलो आपकी जरूर किस चीज की है आईपी
एड्रेस की ठीक है तो आप एपिडर्मिस करते
हैं तो इंटरनेट और जो कम्युनिकेशन होता है
राउटर के कैसे नेटवर्क जो हमारा नेटवर्क
के अंदर जो कम्युनिकेशन होता है थ्रू करते
हैं पर एक्चुअली शुरू हो रहा होता है ठीक
है इस तरीके से वो ट्रांसलेट होता है जैसे
हम जैसा जितने भी google.com पर आईपीएस
कम्युनिकेशन होता है तो नेटवर्क के अंदर
नेगेटिव होता है लेकिन जो नेटवर्क जो
नेटवर्क बात होती है इस नेटवर्क वो कम आई
होता है जैसे ही आपका पैकेट डाटा आपका
नेटवर्क के बाहर भी नेटवर्क में गया है तो
वहां पर डस्टर में रोड शुरू हो गया तो आप
इसे कम नहीं दिया गया ठीक है ना समझ गए
होंगे
चलिए बात कर लेते हैं डीएसबी प्रोटोकॉल की
ठीक है तो
फूल फॉर्म आप का सकते हैं डायनेमिक पोस्ट
कंट्रोल अफ्रीकन प्रोटोकॉल कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
होता है ठीक है चलिए तो डीएसपी का कम क्या
होता है ठीक है ना आप जैसे मां लीजिए कोई
आपका डिवाइस है वो आपको ये नेटवर्क में
कनेक्ट कर रहे हैं आपका फोन है कंप्यूटर
हैक कर रहे हैं कुछ भी कनेक्ट कर रहे हैं
तो उसको एक ड्रेस मिलता है मैंने आपको
बताया था की निक के पास एक हाइड्रोजन तो
होता ही है फिजिकल एड्रेस है उसको मैं
एड्रेस चाहिए ठीक है वो तो परमानेंट है
उसके पास पर आईपी एड्रेस को आसानी हो रहा
है ठीक है तो अभी जो आईपीएल का असाइनमेंट
है ये कौन कर रहा है और कैसे कर रहा है
ठीक है ये रिपीटर तो जो सीमेंट है वो कैसे
हो रहा है तो वो होता है आपका डायनेमिक
पोस्ट कंसोलेशन प्रोटोकॉल की मदद से या तो
उसके सर्वर की वजह से तो बेसिकली आप चाहें
मतलब भी अपने दोस्त को कंफ्यूज कर सकते
हैं एक्चुअली में जो कम हो रहा होता है वो
डायनामिक कंट्रोल प्रोटोकॉल के वजह से हो
रहा है हमारे डेली लाइफ में मतलब इसका है
ये इधर जो लेफ्ट साइड में आपका है ये आपका
ये कंप्यूटर है ठीक है जो आपने अपने
कंप्यूटर को अपने कंप्यूटर सिस्टम को अपने
वाई-फाई से एक्स नेटवर्क कनेक्ट किया यह
अपने दोस्तों कनेक्ट किया तो आपका जो
सिस्टम है वह एक डीएसपी डिस्कवर रिक्वेस्ट
करेगा ठीक है आपका एक जो सिस्टम है वो
डीएक्ससीपी डिस्कवर रिक्वेस्ट करेगा अब वो
रिक्वेस्ट जाएगी डीएसबी सर्वर के पास अब
यहां से थोड़ा शॉर्ट फॉर्म दिया हुआ है वो
रिक्वेस्ट एक्चुअली आई है आपकी डीएसपी
रिले एजेंट के पास तो आप समझते हैं की
डीएसपी डिलिजेंट और डीएसई भी सिर्फ एक ही
में है अब इसमें देखो मतलब वही है तो वो
आपकी जो जीएसटी भी डिस्कवर की रिक्वेस्ट
थी वो आपकी गई डीएसपी सर्वर के पास
एक्चुअली वो एक ब्रॉडकास्ट रिक्वेस्ट सब
के पास जा रही है ठीक है ना वो ऐसा नहीं
है की उसको पता है नहीं बैठा हुआ है बट
स्कोर होना चाहिए क्या यहां पे कोई है जो
मुझे आईपी एड्रेस दे सकता है वो रिपेयर सब
के पास जा रही है तो बाकी कंप्यूटर तो
इग्नोर कर देंगे उसको क्योंकि वो तो डीएसई
भी करवाया नहीं लेकिन जो आपका में आपका जो
डीएसबी सर्वर है अब हमारे नॉर्मल होम कैसे
में हमारा राउटर भी हमारा डीएसपी सर्वर भी
होता है ठीक है तो हमारा आउटर के हां भाई
मैं हूं
डिस्कवर रिक्वेस्ट
तो उसने पूछा भी कोई ऐसा है यहां पर भाई
जो मेरे को आईपी एड्रेस दे पे तो डीएसपी
जो सरवर था आपका उसने कहा हां भाई मैं हूं
डीएसपी सर्वर मैं आपको एक आईपी एड्रेस दे
सकता हूं तो उसने क्या किया अपने डीएसपी
सर्वर या फिर हमारे कैसे में राउटर निक
डीएसपी ऑफर दिया की सर यू कैन हैव 1926 और
1 2 10 ठीक है उसने आपको एक आईपी एड्रेस
दिया है की ठीक है भाई ये आईपी एड्रेस
मौजूद है आप ये आईपी एड्रेस ले सकते हैं
यह आईपी एड्रेस हमारे पास फ्री है इस टाइम
यानी कोई भी त्रिनेट इस आईपी एड्रेस कॉल्ड
नहीं कर रहा है तो आप इस टाइप के ड्रेस को
ले सकते हैं तो अब हमने कहा की ओ सही है
भाई तो हमारे क्लाइंट ने एक डीएसई भी
रिक्वेस्ट की ठीक है ध्यान रहे डीपी
रिक्वेस्ट है वो कहता है ठीक है मैं इस
एड्रेस को लेना चाहूंगा ठीक है मैं जो
डिस्प्ले लेना चाहूंगा
ये वाला बैंड हो जाएगा फिर वो रेनू की हो
सकता है से एड्रेस भी आपको दूसरा एड्रेस
मिल जाएगा ठीक है तो मैं आपको दिखता हूं
आपको मैं
करता हूं
मेरा ये मेरा भी रहेगा इसी में ठीक है
यह मेरा है यहां पर आईपी एड्रेस जो मुझे
मिला हुआ है और ये नीचे लिया हुआ है लेज
ऑब्टेंड यानी कब का ये एपिडर्मिस मुझे
मिला है ठीक और रिलीज एक्सपायर्स कभी आईपी
एड्रेस जो है मेरा एक्सपायरी हो जाएगा
इतने टाइम के बाद ये आईपी एड्रेस रिन्यू
भी हो सकता है मतलब यही है मुझे ऑटम के
लिए मिल जाए दूसरा मिल सकता है ठीक है तो
वो डिपेंड करता है
मैंने आपको याद होगा स्टार्टिंग बताया था
दो तरीके
यही कॉन्सेप्ट यहां पे आप उसको रिलेट कर
का रहे होंगे अगर आपको चीजें यादव अपने
पुराने लेक्चर ढंग से देखा हो तो सेटिंग
मतलब जब आप एक फिक्स आईपी एड्रेस आप सामने
रिक्वेस्ट है मुझे ये वीडियो देखकर खाली
हो तो वहां पर स्टडी करता है हमेशा उसके
लिए अगर आपको सीपीसी स्टडी चाहिए तो आपको
पे भी करना होता है और आउटर में तो खैर आप
उसे कर सकते हैं अपनी प्राइवेट नेटवर्क
में पर डायनामिक यानी चीज होता है ठीक है
अभी आपका ये कल आपको कुछ और होगा
व्हाट्सएप कुछ और होगा इस तरीके से मिलता
है आपको ठीक है ना ये आपका कम होता है
डीएसपी प्रोटोकॉल का और ये कम सर्वर जो है
शाम को अनजान देता है जो की आज का हमारे
डॉक्टर में ही होता है
क्वेश्चन देख लेते हैं क्या है व्हाट टाइप
ऑफ डीएसई भी पैकेट
ड्रेस आईपी एड्रेस करने के लिए मैं कहती
थी डिस्कवरी
हमने कर लिया तो कौन सा भेज रहा है ऑफर
भेज रहा है
नहीं सॉरी एक्चुअली ऑफर नहीं रिक्वेस्ट
ठीक है भाई ठीक है नेक्स्ट है फाइनली
व्हाट इसे डी लास्ट पैकेट था इस सेंट तू
डी डिवाइस
एक्सेप्ट करने के बाद ऑफर यहां पर सेंड
हुआ ऑफर ठीक है रिक्वेस्ट और भी यहां पर
ऑफर के बाद भी क्वेश्चन और रिक्वेस्ट को
एक नॉलेज की आईडी है ठीक है मालिश यानी
ठीक है भाई हमारा सही आईपी एड्रेस
तुम्हारा होगा
ठीक है ये कंप्लीट हो गया तो ये रूम हमारा
कंप्लीट हो चुका है नेक्स्ट हमारा है वो
ऐसा ही मॉडल पे पहले कंप्लीट कर लेते हैं
इसको अगेन टेस्ट शेर करने वाला हूं या तो
आपको शेर करना है हमें टैग करके नहीं करना
है वो नहीं करना है वो करने का तो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है इसका स्क्रीनशॉट लीजिए बटन
दबाया ठीक है और लिखिए क्या क्या पसंद आया
आपको इसके बड़े में इतना मेरे ख्याल से
चलिए
अब यह पेड़ रूम है दोस्तों आप लोग साथ में
नहीं कर पे तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है आपको
साथ नंबर्स फॉलो करता है ना समझते रहना
शुरू ठीक है ना चलिए
तरीके से सेवन लेयर का एक मॉडल है ठीक है
ये कोई प्रैक्टिकल चीज नहीं है ये एक मॉडल
है जो दर्शाता है इस चीज को की डाटा जो है
वो कैसे ट्रांसफर होता है एक डिवाइसेज
डिवाइस में फिर एक नेटवर्क से दूसरे
नेटवर्क में ठीक है कैसे ट्रांसफर हो रहा
है ठीक है जो डाटा है वो कैसे ट्रांसफर हो
रहा है ये साथ लेयर में डिवाइड है जो की
सेवंथ लेयर्स की है एप्लीकेशन
लेयर रिटर्न
क्लियर है ठीक है ओपन
हो में लेफ्ट
जा रही है ना मतलब आपके एप्लीकेशन में कोई
वहां से फिजिकल यानी आपकी तार बन जा रही
है ठीक है तो ये जो प्रोसेस होता है ठीक
है ये आपका तरीके से ये एन कैप्सूलेशन है
ठीक है ये तरीके से आपका एन कैप्सूल है
कैलकुलेशन मतलब की चीजों को रेप किया जा
रहा है मतलब उसके आगे मतलब सेवंथ गियर से
675 में नहीं एड की जा रही है ठीक है तो
ये प्रोसेस आपकी सॉल्यूशन का रहा है वही
चीज पूछा हुआ है इसका
सही है चलिए एप्लीकेशन
लेयर में क्या होता है अगर पिछले
ठीक है
जैसे हम लोग रोज एप्लीकेशन उसे करते हैं
जैसे
हो गया फाइल सर्वर हो गया ठीक है ये सब जो
हम उसे कर रहे हैं ये डाटा को कैसे डाटा
पे कैसे कम करें
आई है एप्लीकेशन
पर एप्लीकेशन
व्हाट इसे डी टेक्निकल टर्म डेट इस जिवन
तू डी नाम ऑफ डी सॉफ्टवेयर डेट यूजर
इंटरेक्ट विद
ओके
ईमेल क्लाइंट्स ब्राउज़र फाइल सर्विस करते
हैं ठीक है या फिर फ्रेंडली ग्रासिकल विद
इंटरफेस ठीक है ये सब हमें ग्रसित इंटरफेस
देता है ना मतलब ये सिचुएशन ईमेल्स वगैरा
आपको दिखा रहा हूं ये चीज तो ये भी एक जी
मिला हुआ है ना हमको डाटा से ट्रैक करने
के लिए ठीक है ये डाटा से इंटरेक्शन हो
रहा है वही चीज है तो ये वही ट्रंप कौन सा
टर्म उसको बुलाया जाता है
ठीक है
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर की
प्रेजेंटेशन
जो होता है ठीक है स्टैंडर्ड जो एक होता
है उसको मेंटेन करता है खाने का मतलब डाटा
से आपका है वो एक फॉर्म होना चाहिए मतलब
अलग-अलग तरीके से बनाए गए हैं हेलो तरीके
से अपने डाटा को प्रिंट कर रहे हैं वो एक
स्टैंडर्ड तरीके से होना चाहिए तो वो कहा
जाता है
प्रेजेंटेशन प्लेयर
की बात है
समझ गए होंगे
ठीक है अब सेशन लेयर में क्या होता है एक
बार डाटा जो है करेक्टली ट्रांसलेट हो गया
फॉर्मेट हो गया प्रेजेंट स्टेशन के लिए
तैयार हो चुका है परंतु ऐसा ही फॉर्मेट
में तो ये सेशन एस्टेब्लिश होता है ठीक है
उसे सेशन में क्या होता है बड़ी डाटा को
स्मॉल स्मॉल चैंप्स में डिवाइड किया जाता
है उसका पैकेट का सकते हैं और चिप्स को
भेजो जाता है ठीक है मतलब
वो सेंड होता है ठीक है बेसिकली यही कम
होता है की सेशन मेंटेन करता है ठीक है
जैसे मेंटेन करता है और आपने डाटा को धीरे
करके सेंड करता है देखिए यही कम है
वही चीज है ठीक है व्हाट इसे डी नाम ऑफ
प्लेयर
एग्रीकल्चर
टेक्निकल टर्म्स पर स्मॉल चेस ऑफ डाटा
स्मॉल चेस ऑफ डाटा क्या कहते हैं पैकेट
कहते हैं
ओके तो सेशन हो रहा है ठीक है ना डाटा
आपका सेशन मेंटेन हो रहा है और पैकेट डाटा
जो आपके हैं वो चेस में डिवाइड हो के सेंड
हो रहे हैं ये कहां आपका सेशन लेयर हो रहा
है ठीक है ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेयर यहां पे एक मेजर रूम पर करता है ठीक
है यहां पे कुछ रेट होता है की जो डाटा
सेंड करना है ठीक है वो कौन से प्रोटोकॉल
के थ्रू सेंड करना है ठीक है
इसके बड़े में मैंने आपको पहले बताया था
और मैंने आपको ये भी कहा था की एक और फोटो
होता है आईसीएलपी उसके बड़े में मैंने
आपको बताया था वैसे तो किसी भी में है
शिल्पी भी है ठीक है
तीसरी मतलब ट्रांसमिशन इंटरप्राइजेज
को ठीक है
ट्रांसफर करता है ये थोड़ा सा स्लो होता
है ठीक है ध्यान रखना है की पूरा लेटर
आंसर होना चाहिए सही से ठीक है यूडीपी
क्या होता है कनेक्शन क्रिएट नहीं किया था
डायरेक्शन डाटा को फिर दिया जाता है समझा
लेकिन मुंह पे जो भाई मिलेगा तो मिलेगा
उसको नहीं मिलेगा ठीक है इसीलिए ये तेज
होता है
और ये इसका ध्यान नहीं रखना है की डाटा
भेजो है जो गया है वो पहुंच है की नहीं
पहुंच है अब अंदर से भेज दिया तो ठीक नहीं
पहुंच तू बेटी ठीक है ये अंतर है
किसी भी एडवांटेज क्या है गावरान हो जाएगा
ठीक है
अगर कोई पैकेट बीच में फैंस गया नहीं जा
पे तो उसको रिसेट कर दिया जाता है ठीक है
डैमेज हो गया ठीक है
वैसे ये काफी स्लो हो जाता है ठीक है यार
ठीक है
किसी का अब ये कनेक्शन कैसे फॉर्म होता है
इसके बड़े में पढ़ेंगे
ठीक है ना ये आपका हो गया अब युटुब का
युटुब में क्या होता है इसीलिए किरण
होता है
डाटा ट्रांसफर होना है ठीक है एप्लीकेशन
कहां पे आएगा
एप्लीकेशन
लेयर में आएगा वहां से सही फॉर्म में
ट्रांसलेट होगा
ठीक है ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर में कस होगा की
किसी भी से करना है ठीक है अब अगर
करने की जरूर है
तो उसमें आपको पहले कनेक्शन रीड करना
पड़ेगा ठीक है तो ये समझ में ए गया आपको
एक चीज हो जाएगा ठीक है अब अगर उप है
उसकी बात कर लेते हैं ठीक है ना कनेक्शन
जो है वो कैसे क्रिएट हो रहा है
कनेक्शन ओरिएंटेड प्रोटोकॉल है मतलब
का पूरा डाटा ट्रांसफर होगा और लास्ट में
कनेक्शन जो है बैंड हो जाएगा ठीक है
प्रोसीजर असम कर लीजिए मां लीजिए की
डिवाइस ए है इसमें डिवाइस बी को डाटा
भेजना है डिवाइस ये है ठीक है तो डिवाइस
ये जो है
वो का सकते हैं आप सीन मतलब सिंक्रोनाइज
सीक्वेंस नंबर फ्लैग ठीक है तो ए बी को एक
सीन पैकेट भेजेगा आपके लिए पैकेट के लिए
उसको एक्सचेंज पैकेट भेजता है इसमें नंबर
है ठीक है फिर क्या होगा
कनेक्शन अगर ए ने बी को भेजो से ठीक है बी
रेडी है तो वो क्या भेजेगा
ठीक है
मैनेजमेंट
तो वो क्या होगा पहले हमने जो सीन भेजो था
ठीक है
इसके सिम का वही प्लस वन ठीक है
इसका डायग्रामेटिक व्यू प्रेजेंटेशन मेरे
ख्याल से ये होगा मैं दिखता हूं उससे आपको
अच्छे से समझ में आएगा आई देखिए ये आपका
डीसीबी क्लाइंट है चाहे इसको क्लाइंट से
ओके चाहे ए और बी के लिए कुछ भी चाहिए तो
क्लाइंट ने सर्वर को पहले सीन भेजो ठीक है
सीन मतलब सिंक्रोनाइज करने की रिक्वेस्ट
मुझे कनेक्ट करना है ठीक है एक बी ने कहा
सरवन ने कहा सन है ठीक है एक मतलब एक
नॉलेज करता हूं क्या करना है
ठीक है वो भेजो अब ये नहीं वापस से एक
मिनट में ठीक है आपने
ठीक है ये थ्री स्टेप में होगा तो इसको
थ्री पे हैंड चेक करते हैं और इसमें जो
नंबर सवाल होगा एक्स ए समझ गए होंगे
इंपॉर्टेंट बस इतना है की तीन स्टेप में
कम हो रहा है
ये होने के बाद आपका टीसीपी का कनेक्शन है
वो बन चुका है अब डाटा ट्रांसफर
होगा खत्म होने के बाद जो खत्म हो जाएगा
तो सिर्फ फ्लेक्स जाता है ठीक है मतलब
फिनिश यानी हमारा कम खत्म हो चुका है
अब खत्म करो
ना यार कुछ ऐसा करना है सवाल कर सकते हैं
ऐसे और भी बहुत सारे फ्लेक्स होते हैं
जो कनेक्शन बन रहा है वो कैसे बन रहा है
और युटुब एक्शन बनाना ही नहीं है डाटा था
वो हमने फेक दो जा रहा जा रहा है उसको मिल
रहा है तो ठीक है नहीं मिल रहा है तो देखो
दिक्कत नहीं है चलिए ये आपका ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेयर की बात हो गई इसी क्वेश्चन को देख
लेते हैं व्हाट इसे डी नाम ऑफ दिस क्लियर
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
तड़प स्टेंस पर ट्रांस
मिशन कंट्रोल
डीबी होता है ठीक है
सवाल होगा ठीक है
आपको वीडियो सरिता कर रहे हैं आपको क्या
चाहिए फास्ट स्पीड चाहिए यार फास्ट स्पीड
नहीं हुई दिक्कत जाएगी आपको ना इसके लिए
हम कस्टमर करते हैं
ठीक है क्योंकि हिस्ट्री में क्या है
देखिए मैं युटुब में सिस्टम की बात नहीं
कर रहा हूं यहां पर पूरा आपके पास स्टोर
है उसके बाद नहीं कर रहा हूं मैं ऐसे
स्टेडियम की जहां लाइव भी चल रहा है देखा
तो देखा आपने आगे बाढ़ गए तो पीछे
तो पुरी डीपी इस्तेमाल होता है ठीक है
क्योंकि जो लॉस हो गया कुछ नहीं पड़ता है
लेकिन स्पीड हनी चाहिए युटुब का इस्तेमाल
करते हैं हम लोग
ये देखिए
ईमेल भी तो सेंड होना ही चाहिए ना वो बात
है
ठीक है ना
ये आपका हो गया ट्रांसपोर्ट
होता है आपके कुछ बेसिक चीज है कौन सा
शॉर्टेस्ट पाठ है नेटवर्क में कौन सा
मोस्ट अवेलेबल है ठीक है और कैसे डाटा
आपको ट्रांसफर होगा मतलब नेटवर्क में
अलग-अलग चीज अलग-अलग है डिवाइस से अलग अलग
है कैसे अपने डाटा को ट्रांसफर करना है
कैसे डाटा
कहां पे है आपकी नेटवर्क प्रोटोकॉल सॉरी
नेटवर्क क्लियर है
मोस्ट ऑप्टिकल राउटर नेटवर्क यस बिल्कुल
पैकेट सबसे आसन सबसे छोटा है
व्हाट टाइप ऑफ एड्रेस
ठीक है
ओके ओके
फ्रॉम डी नेटवर्क प्लेयर डिलीवरी ठीक है
की ये क्या कर रहा है आपका जो मैक एड्रेस
है उसका जो भी हैंडल करना लाइक दिस का वो
कम कर रहा है जोड़ना है ना वो कम इसका है
ठीक है
व्हाट इसे डी नाम
इलेक्ट्रिकल सिग्नल
देता है फाइनली केवल
ट्रांसफर ठीक है
कौन सा नंबर सिस्टम
बाइनरी नंबर सिस्टम मैंने आपको पहले बता
राखी है
व्हाट इसे डी नाम ऑफ डी केवल
इसको हम एन कैप्शन कहते हैं और रिवर्स जब
कोई डाटा रिसीव होता है तो फिजिकल
यानी आपका जो एक्स्ट्रा चीज है वो होती जा
रही है और फाइनली डेट आएगा एप्लीकेशन है
उसको मिल जाता है ठीक है ना इंडियन कोई
चीज है अगर आप इसका स्क्रीनशॉट लेना चाहते
हो तो दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक है ये हो गया
आपका कोई कंप्लीट अब यहां पर
अब ये बेसिक चीज है कई बार ऐसे गेम्स आपको
ये गेम बेकार भी होते हैं जैसे कुछ फायदा
नहीं है
की आप रूम पर कंप्लीट करते हैं जैसे होता
है ना कभी आंसर नहीं मिलता है की कौन सा
शब्द उसे हो रहा है
शेर कर सकते हैं
ओके यह मैं खड़ा हूं यहां पर ससुराल में
कौन से लिए जाऊंगा
उसका ठीक है
नेटवर्क क्लियर है ठीक है आपका यहां पर
ठीक है इसका क्या हो गया ट्रांसपोर्ट
ट्रांसपोर्ट
ठीक है
फिर कहां जाएगा
कर कर लेते हैं
आपका वैसा ही मॉडल का हिसाब स्क्रीनशॉट ले
सकते हैं ठीक है टीसीपी आईपी मॉडल इसका ये
एडवांस बाढ़ जाएगा क्योंकि वैसे मॉडल नहीं
होता है ठीक है तो थोड़ा सा रियल शब्द से
नीरज बनाया जाए तो टीसीपी मतलब कर सकते
हैं
रियल
वही चीज है
इसमें जो फोर्स लेयर होती है वो इंसानियत
के बराबर होती है ठीक है ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
इंटरनेट प्लेयर और नेटवर्क ठीक है
एप्लीकेशन ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेयर ठीक है वो आपके वैसे ही मॉडल के
एप्लीकेशन के बराबर होती है उनसे कोई कम
करती है ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर जो होती है
ट्रांसपोर्ट करती है इंटरनेट ने जो होती
है वो उसके नेटवर्क प्लेयर को ही कहा जाता
है
और जो नेटवर्क इंटरफेस लेयर होती है ये
आपकी रिटर्निंग के लिए है तो फिजिकल लेयर
का कम करती है ठीक है
तो ये हो गया नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम लोग
क्या देखेंगे देख लेते हैं अभी थोड़ा सा
पैकेट और फ्रेंड्स
टाइगर श्रॉफ
वही चीज है ठीक है
और प्रैक्टिकल भी हम करेंगे अभी
स्टार्टिंग में थोड़ी आएगा ये आम बातें
नेटवर्किंग का पढ़ रहे हैं आपको
स्टार्टिंग में थ्योरी रहेगी लेकिन
स्टार्टिंग धीरे-धीरे जब हम आगे बढ़ते
रहेंगे तो प्रैक्टिकल भी आएंगे सर ठीक है
बहुत प्रैक्टिकल उसमें नहीं होता है
स्टार्टिंग में आगे ही होता है क्योंकि
होता है लेकिन वो आपके सपोर्ट के ऊपर है
बार-बार वही चीज का रहा हूं क्योंकि आप
शेर बहुत नहीं कर रहे हैं अभी तक किसी का
टास्क मेरे का चार-पांच महीने लेक्चर ए
रहा है फिर भी कोई टास्क किसी ने नहीं
किया इतना दिखेगा मुझे उतना में एक्सटेंड
करूंगा उतना ज्यादा चीज इसमें लॉन्ग आपके
लिए ठीक है फिलहाल इसको आपको इतना कर सकते
हैं आप फ्री में रख सकते हैं पेड़ अकाउंट
नहीं तो टास्क पूरा करने के बाद प्लीज
टेलीग्राम फीडबैक दिया करो आप लोग ठीक है
अगर आपको निर्मित नहीं करना है हालांकि
आपको निर्मित करना चाहिए उससे फायदा है वो
देखेंगे एक्टिव है ठीक है लेकिन अगर आपको
आप नहीं भी करना है तो आप भी कीजिए देखिए
फीडबैक लीजिए जब की जो भी आपके मां में जो
आपने शिखा था ठीक है नेक्स्ट मैं ये सब
पढ़ेंगे हम लोग और सर फिर हम लोग ये दोनों
अपडेट करने के बाद जाएंगे